[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
on a un comportement que saleh lequel
l'amour dévastée oui c'est vrai la
mauvaise tenue je trouve assez sobre ce
soir je crois que vous avez dépassé en
fait je voulais vous laisser toute la
lumière va les réceptions
j'ai l'impression position avec mon fils
a permis de
faire l'émission ma mère
très content de voir gad elmaleh valérie
bénaïm succès dans leur avancée shabbat
le jeu
alors dites moi mon petit sacha oui
cyril cyril me manquent certes mais je
vais en profiter vu qu'il n'est pas là
pour envoyer du dossier sur les digues
je sais tout je vois tout je dénonce
tous les gros trucs sur ce ring oui
alors si elle savait qui fait des
bêtises chaque soir en direct dans tpm p
mais est-ce que vous soulevez de
l'émission culture pub pierre sueur et
la douane ba ba dum ba pub alors pour
ceux à la maison qui ne connaissent pas
c'était une émission qui dévoilait un
peu les coulisses de la publicité les
garçons connaissent un peu mieux puisque
c'était juste avant les films un peu
coquine et a86
[Applaudissements]
eh
bien figurez vous qu'un à café
ressuscité qui ressuscite d'ailleurs
cette émission chaque soir dans tpm p
c'est cyril leroy du placement de
marques en loucedé
[Musique]
mais je garde elle avait été choqué très
choqués et c'était partout où j'ai
aménagé des délits choqué
et mike horn également survivants des
glaces il a volé toutes les glaces
häagen-dazs
démarré on avait aujourd'hui la
confiance est perdue il ya que j'ai
confiance qu'on darty
[Musique]
riel robin j'adore j'adore regarder arte
et gère tout d'arreter thiam la chaîne
j'aime la pizza
et on aura également dans un instant
aussi patrick joue le frère de jimmy
[Rires]
c'est vrai en plus en arles affirmé
niccolo ghedini c'est vrai j'aimerais me
suis enfin arrivé moi j'ai enfin rivage
il a dit et c'était un choix de société
qui est évident et on est à 60 ans les
seuls choix de société c'est roquefort
[Applaudissements]
qui touche à chaque fois où je pense
vraiment et où josé un truck series
mais il regarde pas ou presque en parle
bien sûr que je vais répéter c'est les
vallées loto de set up aussi
rappelle cyril valery c'est
vrai nous la sap annonce valérie il ya
un chroniqueur autour de cette table et
qui mérite une sanction ah bon on
pourrait même dire qu'il mérite une très
grosse fessée car oui oui mais attention
parce que si c'est moi qui la donnent
petit nom savalli sarkozy a placé chez
moi
[Rires]
je vous donne un avis si je vous dis
porte parole du gouvernement
depuis que celui-ci fréquent que les
hauts lieux de cette société monsieur
est en roue libre c'est le retour de
bernard dit le mot
qui sait leur mal qu'a fait le reportage
là ce qui m'a pas mis en photo avec eux
richard holmes qu'il est gentil lui il
est gênant
du site
c'est méchant de dire ça à ta grand mère
isabelle parce que a priori
quelques chroniqueurs serez capable de
renier cyril contre un gros chèque et de
changer de chaîne dès le 1er janvier
2022 moi je me casse dire
franchement n'attendez pas qu'on les
champions montre
les patines voyez ça oui oui mais si
samuel eto'o kaka et messi parc avec moi
elle touche le toucher
et cibray d'amitié amoureuse mon cul ou
les
fonds de la côte d'amour elles dépendent
du succès que vous verrez c'est ça c'est
tout du succès alors là tout le monde
vous adore août formida comme vous en ce
moment ça va pas durer sûrement
très attractive
bangle n'est pas terminée
pour moi tu apprends des trucs tu vois
oui beaucoup de réussite et vous pouvez
sortir de ma caméra ça me gêne parce
qu'on me voit pas là
tu désolé non c'est ce qu'on fait à la
télé maintenant que dès que dès que de
cadres
que je
m'étais bien des héros s'il vous plaît
savez quoi mais ta grand-mère l'acalf m
pour
non mais
on
se connaît depuis très très longtemps
très longtemps à l'époque de tf1 on est
fière absolument pas comme ça mais non
vous êtes arrivé là bas c'est depuis que
vous fréquentez
bien et lui étaient mignons gendre idéal
et maintenant je suis venu
la haute lande et qui de cyril steam
parce que même en coulisses et je suis
l'indiquent quand on lui met le micro
déjà aux ingénieurs du son qui sont très
sympas eu des attaques grand-mère est
quant à lui mais le micro et du matin
qu'elle peut mettre dans ton cul alors
on va alors ça c'est vrai
mais ça m'amuse c'est l'expression que
vous utilisez souvent
ça me plaît bien oui je suis moi on
parle pas comme ça on est très châtié
chez nous rien n'est donc ça me plaît ta
grand mère mais c'est toujours avec
beaucoup de respect un bâtiment et la
latence avait le plus terrible c'est que
cette émission est en direct comme ce
soir oui et que quand je vois tout ce
que j'ai pu dire c'est quand même un peu
gênant
[Applaudissements]
cc il y aura pas de façon lascive et
quand c'est un privé tu veux là
maintenant je veux bien faire plaisir
bien
tu m'as fait c'est au sein du pq
[Applaudissements]
je vais d'abord sur un moment mal
stv2 malaise est très gênant très
gênante gênante et jalouse jamais je
n'aurais jamais pas du tout non mais je
n'ai pas des plus longtemps s'ils
avaient voulu de pcm leur ai demandé
depuis longtemps et je n'aurais fait un
des plaisirs mais hamilton est passée la
7ème avenue agence plateau
qui m'est venue tout le monde s'était vu
du bon bah oui surtout du bruit c'est
vrai qu'à l'occasion s'il vous plaît
non pas parce qu'on partage et des loges
et puis les parties publiques comme
garçon ou à lyon mais voilà quand
c'était dans le centre de mon fils dont
payet d'aia prescription aux bonis
non mais voilà non mais c'est des vrais
amis de longue date allez on y va
c'est bien connu
c'est pas mal à l'époque un homme un
vrai bon
non
très très bien mais à l'époque
très bon tout le secteur très bien et
elle est à poil numa est un poil mettait
à poil d'ailleurs il n'a pas de poils
je suis totalement inverse
[Rires]
j qui présente l'émission là haut est
l'ami la patache capelle
c'est le volet
c'est normal je redis à céline je vous
embrasse mon chéri je pense très fort à
toi c'est une belle et rim et valérie
j'ai lancé la semaine dernière une
séquence que vous avez adoré à la maison
ça s'appelait le polnabb est adoré à la
maison et
j'ai reçu plein de messages sont revenus
à mon avis oui elles sont maintenant ça
parlait mais relève que c'est très bien
oui mais on gère de l'année on reprend
le principe pour ceux qui n'étaient pas
là pour ce qui du coup n'aurait pas aimé
n'aurait pas vu je vais dénicher dans
les petites images du pape du cinoche
tous les chroniqueurs qui voudraient
arrondir leurs fins de mois ça s'appelle
le haut la vue et je peux vous dire
qu'il ya d'énormes pépite cette semaine
regarde
et on commence avec bernard antienne qui
on l'a vu en sharon stone visiblement et
l'horrible mettre une culotte d'une
surface mancelle très belle serait
vraiment le territoire
national la cgt
cet hommage de vanille
et c'est pas fini on a fait comme
j'entends la france a soumises s'est
embrouillé avec marine le pen et les
colères j'entends c'est vous et c'est
vous parce que vous parce que
bercy mais qu'ils allaient celle là
l'udf et le pc on a vu au casting des
visiteurs 4 isabelle morini bosc à
nicolas pernikoff c'est dingue
mais si je veux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je peux te la faire virer mais on a vu
le patron de la chaîne seront capitaux
qui visiblement s'est déjà paré en
vacances au ski y
voit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un piéton en revanche bernard lhez
bernard tout-va oui et torride mais
c'est agréable d'ailleurs j'ai entendu
zabel qui disait on dirait françoise
sagan je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
beaucoup de français je me souviens du
tournage j'étais très ému
vous aviez une cliente ou pas alors
finalement bien sûr que non alors voir
parce que franchement il est
exceptionnel vers la ville
exceptionnelle
ça aurait vraiment été super décrit
l'histoire d'amour de tuer ensuite
l'intérêt qu'elle est ce que vous voulez
encore bien
sûr ces nouvelles encore
et bien on a vu chez le père des super
vénère après qu'un mec est encore celle
et fatou et
[Applaudissements]
on a vu fabrice di vizio qui ça y est il
est enfin vacciner on vous l'a dit
fabrice attention aux effets secondaires
[Musique]
de leurs mots avant sa chirurgie
dentaire très franchement c'est pas mon
beauf
et on finit le meilleur cyril tout le
monde le croit dans son lit avec de la
fièvre mais en fait pas du tout il vient
de partir en week end en ouzbékistan
[Musique]
syrine qu'il a de la fièvre y ressemble
à ça et il a il dort avec un petit filet
comme ça ça lui va très bien oui bon on
embrasse payeurs mais
je sais qu'il me regarde pas mal rires
je vous croyais que j'allais repartir
sans parce que je vous ai vu aussi
me tenais mon ami e vous avez récupéré
beaucoup de pages valeo
[Applaudissements]